.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la première sortie
d'un camion nommé "Livroooum".
Et il ne passe pas inaperçu.
(enfants émerveillés)
♪ ♪ ♪
Le véhicule servira
de bibliothèque pour des écoles
primaires qui n'en ont plus.
Au Centre de services scolaire
de Montréal, c'est le cas
dans une vingtaine d'écoles
qui manquent de locaux.
Comme le problème perdure,
des bibliothécaires ont trouvé
une solution.
VIVIANE MORIN, bibliothécaire,
chargée de projet, CSSDM
- L'idée, c'est de recréer
un peu l'expérience
de la bibliothèque. Donc, on va
s'installer environ 3-4 jours,
le temps de voir vraiment
tous les élèves de l'école,
et on s'installe aussi autour
du camion, donc recréer un peu
une classe extérieure.
On s'assoit sur des poufs.
- Vous allez me dire : "Ah, moi,
j'aimerais ça avoir un livre
de Mortelle Adèle!"
- Ce que promet le projet-pilote
fait déjà briller les yeux
de ces élèves de 3e année.
- Lire, ça t'aide à devenir
intelligent.
- On peut apprendre de nouveaux
mots qu'on connaissait pas
encore.
- Il y a plein d'imagination
qui vient dans ma tête.
MÉLISSA MORNEAU, enseignante
de 3e année, École des Monarques
- Fait que la lecture, c'est
vraiment quelque chose de super
important puis en 3e année,
c'est l'étape où on commence
à devenir meilleur lecteur,
qu'on comprend un petit peu plus
l'entreligne.
- Le projet, financé par le
ministère de l'Éducation,
compte rassembler jusqu'à
15 000 livres et desservir
1700 élèves du primaire.
- Nous, notre mot-clé,
je dirais, c'est la variété,
hein. Donc, vraiment avoir
un peu de tout. On veut
les intéresser à la lecture,
les accrocher, développer
l'habitude de lire, donc on va
aller chercher leurs intérêts.
- À l'intérieur ici, il va
y avoir tout plein de rayonnages
avec des livres.
- Le camion transportera
2000 livres à la fois.
L'aménagement et la mise à
niveau mécanique sont réalisés
par des centres de formation
du CSSDM.
Les élèves ont aussi rencontré
l'artiste.
MARC-OLIVIER LAMOTHE, graffeur
- Les gens avec qui j'ai
travaille m'ont prêté...
Ils m'ont livré des livres
pour m'inspirer, pour créer
ce dessin.
- J'adore comment tu fais.
- C'est vrai.
- Merci.
- Il y a encore du travail
à faire. Ce n'est qu'à la
prochaine rentrée scolaire que
Livrouuum prendra officiellement
la route.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, M